i'm doing a PhD in neuroscience under
the Department of Medicine and my main
focus of the investigation of the visual
aspects of psychedelics was a privilege
to be the other side to experience kind
of a subject side of things and I was
injected with LST 75 micrograms of Alice
T I didn't really know what I want to
expect being in the scanner is very it's
a very different situation
the experience was actually nice and
then after that they kind of saw that
I'm okay there's no drug effects and
after that i went to the park and
afterglow of the drug bit in the park
so in addiction and also in depression
sometimes the patients are quite locked
in certain patterns of thought and maybe
this allows them in the moment of the
therapy session to be more flexible and
kind of investigated different parts of
their personality or their mind and
through that and kind of learn new
things about himself from the therapy
session